une évidence l'information sexuelle à
l'école ce n'était plus possible d'y
échapper
les quelques élèves de 6e et 5e qui
auraient encore des doutes sur les choux
et l'hérault seront fixés une bonne foi
c'était des blacks en sciences nat ils
étudieront les mécanismes de la
procréation d'une manière exclusivement
scientifique précise la circulaire
ministérielle dans beaucoup
d'établissements
on avait déjà abordé le problème c'est
sur les rapports que tu sais déjà des
choses
oh oui quand même je sais fois par mes
parents mes parents me copain cocu ça on
en parle des fois j'aimerais c'est qu'on
m'apprenne sur le plan scientifique et
sur le plan affectif aussi parce que en
général en troisième on sait beaucoup de
choses mais on sait pas tout enfin les
barons nous l'apprennent une question la
question scientifique il nous apprenait
exactement ce que c'est que que l'amour
exactement mais nous le disent pas sur
le plan vraiment effectif moral dès
qu'un enfant apprend à parler il est
capable de poser certaines questions
ludiques alimenter ce qu'on sait plutôt
que d'inventer des femmes venues manque
un petit enfant né dans une dans un show
que je suis comme ça c'est complètement
idiot lançant la prendrais bien assez
tôt il en faudra aux parents de ne pas
lui avoir parlé
maman maman m'a dit qu'elle attendait
les questions de moi mais moi je
n'attendais plus tôt de son côté qu'elle
m'apporte sur ce sujet là je trouve que
c'est assez difficile d'en parler avec
les parents votre papa je sais pas en
parler avec lui faut l'aborder avec
pour être le parent ou alors
ou alors carrément avec un médecin ou à
6 4 c'est pas pareil du professeur
information sexuelle mais pas éducation
sexuelle reconnaissant que la frontière
est difficile voire impossible à établir
les professeurs le savent et beaucoup ne
cache pas un certain trac physiologie il
faut savoir la bordée d'abord votre
savoir prendre la température de la
classe parce que réagit enfin dix ans
les élèves ne réagissent pas tous de la
même façon je suis pour l'éducation
sexuelle je lis tout de suite à l'école
mais je crois qu'il faut l'aborder de
manière très prudente et c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi nous sommes tous
actuellement assez je peux dire le mot
presque angoisses et sur la manière dont
nous allons l'aborder et il faut prendre
de grands soins justement d'aborder dans
les meilleures conditions psychologiques
possibles chez cette année des élèves
pour lesquels une forme d'éducation
sexuelle ne me paraît pas du tout
opportune ce sont des élèves qui sont
naïfs et je pense qu'on ne peut pas le
leur imposer du moins leur proposait
même en cas de volontariat une éducation
sexuelle des avantages importants de
l'éducation sexuelle c'est de donner aux
enfants vocabulaire pour pouvoir parler
des choses sexuelles
ils ont l'habitude de se servir de nos
bulles guerre qu'ils n'osent pas employé
devant les adultes
et quand on leur donne les mots qui
conviennent il se trouve tout de suite
beaucoup plus à leur aise pour en parler
et quand on n'obtiendrait que ce
résultat ce serait déjà à la qui est
nerveux et les parents on leur a souvent
reproché leur silence aux questions
posées par leurs enfants dans le domaine
de la sexualité
je trouve que cette information sexuelle
est nécessaire elle est indispensable
qu'elles soient faites à l'école puisque
les parents ne la font pas il vaut mieux
qu'elle se fait à l'école que pas du
tout mais je pense qu'elle serait même a
commencé aux primaires moi j'ai 40 ans
pour marina ventes de plus déjà un petit
roman et lui
une génération alors c'est un problème
puis incroyable moi j'ai déjà évolué
pour la volonté d'évoluer à 21 ans vous
avez du couple de mot nage que le
problème se pose ne veulent pas parler à
leurs femmes c'est l'occasion pour lés
parents de pouvoir en parler avec les
enfants ça va être la goutte d'eau qui
va leur permettre l'ouverture maintenant
seront ils en profitent et ça c'est
autre chose